The A to Z of isms... populism.
Populism sounds like democracy in action.
It's all about looking after the little guy,
hearing what ordinary people want
and giving it to them -or at least promising to give it to them.
Oddly though, 'populist' is almost always a pejorative term -no one really wants the label.
Most populist leaders would rather
see themselves as inspiring grassroot movements.
Populism has been around at
least since ancient Roman times,
with emperor's lavishing money on food and entertainment, bread and circuses to appeal
to the masses.  The English Civil War, the
French Revolution, the Brexit referendum,
Donald Trump's rise to power -all these
came from populist groundswells of
opinion against elites and the status
quo. When a populist movement gets big
enough and doesn't get what it wants, it
gives the mainstream the finger by
winning an election. So what could be
wrong with a charismatic leader focusing
the will of the people and millions
voting for what they believe in?
When populists choose to vote rather than revolt
isn't this just what democracy looks like when it's working? Well, some people see it
that way... But there's more to democracy
than voting, at least more to liberal
democracy. In functioning democracies
disagreement and dissent are part of the
political process. Political debate
involves reason, evidence, challenge and
argument. Free speech and a free press
are vital to this.
Populists, in contrast, love stirring hearts with rhetoric, aren't renowned for using
evidence and argument, and are keen on
dividing the world into 'us' and 'them'.
They're prone to scapegoating
journalists, elites and foreigners and to
conspiracy theories about why the world
isn't as they want it to be.
Political opponents are dismissed as not
understanding what ordinary people want.
The real danger in populism though is
that it can morph into authoritarianism.
When populist leaders believe they're in
touch with the spirit of the people
heaven help anyone who stands in
their way.
The fervor of populist politics could be
truly terrifying, as the French Revolution demonstrated.
The philosopherJean-Jacques Rousseau, whose ideas contributed to it,
provides a chilling warning of where unfettered populism can end up.
He declared that citizens who
disagreed with the general will of the people,
should be forced to be free. That's a very long way from sticking up for the little guy.